[Music]
viewers might love the Dutton family but
the family tree is starting to get
complicated our fans getting exhausted
from the Yellowstone spin-offs or could
the creators make one simple fix to
clear up the confusion there are a few
certainties that we can expect in life
death and taxes might be some of them
but so is the fact that Taylor Sheridan
will continue to pump out Yellowstone
content the writer first gained
commercial success by Penning films such
as sicario and hell or high water but
his true mark on pop culture is
Paramount's hit series about the Dutton
family and their attempt to hold on to
their Ranch in the face of the modern
world John Dutton uses violence power
and the skills of his children to keep
his way of life so popular is the series
that Sheridan created a prequel
detailing the Dutton family's shocking
moments in 1883 which premiered in
December 2021 it Chronicles the lives of
John's ancestors James and Margaret
Dutton as they embark on a perilous
journey across the American West this
program kept the momentum going leading
to the eventual creation of 1923
starring Helen mirin as Cara Dutton and
Harrison is Jacob Dutton the new batch
of episodes has some serious Star
Quality attached to it but his fans
tuned in to the premiere they couldn't
help but note that the series had some
confusing aspects specifically the ever
expanding family tree of the Dutton
family the purpose of any prequel is to
connect to the original story after all
without Yellowstone there would be no
1883 or 1923. viewers are excited to see
the origins of the Dutton Dynasty but as
it turns out those Origins are getting a
bit complicated fans on Twitter were
thrown into a tailspin trying to figure
out how everyone was related one Twitter
user wrote I need someone to make a
family tree of the duttons because I'm
so confused will Spencer Dutton in 1883
with only 40 years in between prequel
series many were trying to figure out if
some characters were adult versions of
any 1883 characters some Twitter users
were lamenting the lack of an official
family tree to keep everything straight
luckily there were some answers to be
found on Reddit at least when it
concerned how Yellowstone factored into
the story one redditor also wondered if
James dutton's youngest son Spencer was
in 1883 while another user just wanted
to know if these characters were John
dutton's direct relations one user
stepped in with some clarification
saying Jacob Dutton is James dutton's
brother whose son John Dutton senior is
John Dutton III's great-grandfather with
so many similar sounding J names it's a
wonder anyone can keep it all straight
a week thinking a way to [ __ ] up my day
I could not have come up with this
in a relatively short span of time the
Dutton Clan has increased in size
dramatically and it stands to reason
that as long as there's some interest in
Yellowstone media the family tree will
continue to get bigger thankfully for
those struggling to figure out who's
related to who and how you'll get some
time to iron out the details very soon
without having to close off from the
sprawling Yellowstone franchise the next
two planned installments look to be
Shifting the focus away from the duttons
in favor of other characters coming up
next from the mind of Taylor Sheridan is
four sixes based on the ranch of the
same name that popped up during
Yellowstone the spin-off is set to debut
sometime in 2023 though an official date
for its Premiere has yet to be announced
then there's 1883 the bass Reeves story
which was announced in 2022 and will
serve as an offshoot of 1883 as the
title implies It Centers on Reeves
himself who is the first black U.S
Marshal in history David oyelowa will
star having spent quite a while
attempting to get the show off the
ground despite their diminished
prominence and upcoming Yellowstone
adjacent titles the duttons will always
sit at the core of the franchise one can
only hope that the family tree doesn't
get more confusing from here
[Music]